kyle rittenhouse defending himself from
media attacks in his first interview
after a jury found him not guilty on all
five charges in his double murder trial
we have brand new preview clips of his
exclusive sit down with tucker carlson
tonight at 8 pm eastern the 18 year old
reacting to the verdict
in my opinion there's no winners in this
case there's no heroes in this case
i defended myself i was attacked
rittenhouse also blasting the way his
case became politicized
they're saying you can go out and riot
and attack anybody and you will have the
support from the media and the
politicians to do whatever you want and
kill innocent people and if they defend
yourself you're named a hero that's the
message i believe is being spread and
despite being called out for
misrepresenting key facts in the case
the media is doubling down on their
attacks against rittenhouse
rittenhouse drove in from illinois armed
for battle the fact that white
supremacists roam the halls of congress
freely and celebrate this little
murderous white supremacist and the fact
that he gets to walk the streets freely
it lets you know these people have
access to instituting
laws welcome to the modern republican
party this is what these people want and
this is what a majority of white people
vote for it's a warning to every white
suburbanite with a black lives matter
poster in their window those people now
know that they too
can be shot by a white 17 year old with
an ar-15 if he feels threatened by their
desire to see america live up to its
potential
and then just one more piece of sound
from tucker's interview with him and
talking about what he believes is really
on trial here
it wasn't kyle reddenhouse on trial in
wisconsin it was the right to
self-defense on trial i'm not a racist
person i support the blm movement i
support peacefully demonstrating
and i believe there needs to be change i
believe there's a lot of prosecutorial
misconduct not just in my case but in
other cases
and it's just amazing to see
how
how much a prosecutor can take advantage
of somebody so the verdict jesse did not
settle things really in the minds of the
media and the public in particular they
couldn't respect the jury trial and they
continue to attack him yeah uh before we
start i just want to let you know that
waters world has also had a documentary
film crew embedded with someone also
very high profile for about a year
that person's gut felt
we're going to be releasing this on
waters world originals on fox station
full access thanks for your cooperation
my pleasure it's eye-opening let's put
it that way so when you watch written
house on tucker
you don't see the way the media has
characterized him you see a guy who
looks pretty measured open-minded
thoughtful person and when you look at
him testify too what do you see see
someone who was scared for his life
crying real tears and honestly someone
who was there in kenosha that night to
help not to harm but the media makes him
look like some vigilante who's out on
some racist killing spree just using his
white tears in order to literally beat a
murder rap so why
do we have this so it's because they do
character assassination and
psychological warfare this kid 17 turned
his whole phone over to the prosecution
now a phone
is really a window into someone's
personality at 17
the prosecution didn't bring up a meme a
group text an account that he was
following there was nothing to make this
kid look racially motivated at all yet
the media knowing this still continued
to slander him as a white supremacist
that's malicious and reckless obviously
and then it's the drum beat of lies that
this guy crossed state lines with an
illegal assault rifle to in you know
vigilante justice these are debunked
lies
so that's basically a disinformation
campaign on the american people
they're laying siege to the american
people's brain
and that's the most toxic thing you can
do to a population and so the american
people now know this and they're
basically going through a detox of
mainstream media they're they're
cleansing they're they're taking cnn out
of their diet they're taking msnbc out
of their diet now when they're presented
with a fax from a reputable source
they don't trust that they're suspicious
of these facts
they've broken up with them we're on our
own we're single now we're going to do
our own journalism we're going to look
online and we're going to find the facts
for ourselves and that is a huge shift
in the way this country's gone and
that's why the legacy media is so scared
because they can see their power
falling away and they've become so
desperate in trying to hold it on and
that's how you see the lies keep piling
up judge
you know i think that when you watch
kyle rittenhouse you see a young boy
who's turned into a man after a a course
of events that would change any of us
he uh in talking about prosecutorial
misconduct but at the same time talking
about the right to self-defense and
articulating it so well uh from what
i've seen so far and and testifying
brilliantly better than probably any
witness i've seen in 30 years
we realized that this kid in the future
may have a lot to offer in terms of
society as long as he uses his life in a
way that he has
you know
shown us he would as a police explorer
and a fire cadet and someone who's a
lifeguard and someone who wanted to be a
medic i think he's a giving kid i think
that what's not giving is the media the
media will never forgive this young man
they will never allow him to live the
life that he wants to lead he will never
be safe there are people who believe
that he's a white supremacist that we
are all white supremacists that the
jurors i'm sure are all white
supremacists the judge and every one of
us are white supremacists and i feel
badly for him because i think he's not
going to be able to live a normal life
in that regard but having said all that
the law the facts the evidence were
clear this is a classic case of
self-defense and what's better than
anything i've seen is the video and we
are now in an age where technology is
giving us a bird's-eye view of what is
happening to crime to crime victims and
crime on the streets we're seeing them
in real time we're seeing what they're
doing we've got witnesses with phones we
are now closer to justice than we've
ever been in the history of this country
where we had to rely on people's
memories et cetera et cetera except for
that well that might be true but then
the media reporting like the montage we
just showed you like they're not even
considering the facts the scariest thing
about that montage uh is that
the average white person doesn't want to
harm a black person the average white
person the big secret wants to actually
help blacks uh and they and it's proven
time and time again that's like that's
just what people do
what they are saying those talking heads
are that
white people want to hurt you i mean
that's what they i mean it's it's like
they're roaming the world but anyway i
uh you know there will be critics that
say do not make rittenhouse into a hero
and i get it but these are the people
that have been kept saying that jacob
blake
was an unarmed good samaritan helping
out his family this is from the people
who are engaging or encouraging people
to march on behalf of a dead pedophile
you know there were two two people that
died uh at the hands of kyle rittenhouse
the disturbing trend
is not how happy we are that they died
but how little their crimes matter to
the left and to the people that are
calling them you know martyrs and
something these were not black activists
one was a pedophile another was a
spousal abuser these these are the worst
people on the planet and they went after
the wrong guy and they paid for it uh
this is why the media keeps asking the
same question if kyle was black would he
be treated differently we've heard that
from a lot of people but those are
people who are are using their only
singular race lens if
the fact is if if kyle was black he
would be our nominee for the president
for 2024 because we see everything
through the self-defense lens we don't
we
everybody here on this table it's like
where's my glasses it's like we're at
the optometrist when we're looking at an
issue we go better
is this better is this better we all
have all these multiple lenses uh
sometimes i don't even have any like i
have no lens for sports i have no lens
for business but i do have a good lens
for law and order i have a good lens for
self-defense um
we can shift these things but if you
just have a one prism and that's race
then you're gonna miss this entire story
and that's what happened that's why
everybody on msnbc and their viewers
were shocked that this verdict was such
a surprise because how could this be
didn't he kill two black people isn't he
white supremacist how did how how did
this happen in this unjust world it's
because no because you were relying on
the one race lens if you had a number of
other ones at your at your yes if you
had those self-defense lens you could
have actually seen this and you could
also look at what happened with this uh
guy that just got found not guilty when
the swat team came after him
self-defense that's i can't his name
slips in my mind well and one thing
harold that i think fueled a lot of the
politization of it was it and this
happened
and after the summer of george floyd and
then you had the presidential campaign
and president biden and then then the
candidate called kyle rittenhouse a
white supremacist and then
kind of said well i accept the jury
trial but then again tried to undermine
and what do you think about the way he
and harris handled this in the aftermath
well first off i want this young man to
be able to reset his life and regain
regain a grip on life and i agree with
the judge i
you know i heard him today say that he
supports black lives matter
uh that there's a lot of complexity a
lot of not a dimension sim that that we
don't know about and i hope that to the
extent he wants us to learn about that i
hope we're able to
uh two i listened to both the president
and the vice president they're both
lawyers both to tried cases
they said it the way they wanted to say
it and they both accepted the verdict
they had some commentary and i wasn't
surprised by that
what i i'm most sort of taken aback by
as i think about this going forward and
i think about my own life and i think
about
going into a grocery store or restaurant
and someone coming in perhaps with a
grievance with a server or clerk or
manager or someone in one of those
places and they might have a weapon and
they might be going after that person i
might be with my son or my daughter and
i may try to restrain him or her ask him
to please stop and if if the way we've
interpreted some of these self-defense
laws and this our very case is really
going to be interesting to me the
outcome of that perhaps more so than the
written house case because it seems like
there's the elements there in the
self-defense issue uh or and judge you
would be far more informative too to
analyze this but
if you come in a grocery store
restaurant and you're with your family
and you try to restrain someone and they
shoot you
and they are charged and they say in
court i was
defending myself because jesse was
coming after me harold was coming after
me i was just trying to restrain him i
hope we i hope legislators who i don't
think contemplated that kind of
self-defense really think about some of
these things as we as we think about
perhaps refining some of these laws
going forward but i wish this kid the
best and he's in my prayers
did you have one last quick thing this
kind of thing that you just described is
something that courts have dealt with
for years that i've dealt with for years
that you are you reasonably afraid of
that person and therefore you can defend
yourself i mean
he made it but he may think i'm coming
after him and maybe shoot me in right it
depends i mean it's okay that's why you
have this man or woman okay all right
i'm done all right we'll move on up next
shocking new details in this holiday
parade tragedy while why bail reform
could be to blame we'll be right back
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else